but there is still much work to do we
still have inflation that is much too
high that's causing a lot of pressure
for families up and down the country
that's why we've got to stick to our
plan to get inflation down to get growth
up and to get the economy Motoring in
the way that we all want
the UK Remains the only G7 country in
which the quarterly measure of GDP has
not recovered to its pre-covered level
in March the economy went backwards when
will we get back to where we were three
years ago
if you look at the most up-to-date
monthly figures we are now above
pandemic levels across the whole economy
but only marginally and we want to see
much faster growth that's why we need to
stick to our plan above all to bring
inflation down because that's a drag on
growth but also part of that plan is to
relieve the pressure on families as we
go through this difficult period that's
why we've increased this month the
national living wage to its highest ever
level we're doing big payments to help
people with their electricity bills but
the long-term solution is not subsidy
it's actually getting inflation down and
growth up and on the quarterly basis
when will we get back to where we were
I think it's for the economist to say
um when we are going to get our costly
levels back to pre-pandemic levels but
Germany is also in the same situation as
we are the bigger picture here is that
growth is picking up much faster than
anyone thought possible that's
encouraging the international monetary
fund here in Japan with me say that the
British economy is on the right track
but there's much to do we've still got
to get inflation down and we've got to
stick to our plan to make sure we remove
those pressures on people's weekly
shopping bills strike action is holding
that growth it's also leading to
canceled operations and school closures
when will you resolve these disputes
we want to resolve the public sector
strikes as quickly as we can we're
prepared to be completely reasonable we
will talk about anything except measures
that will entrench high inflation
because the root cause of the anger of
the people who are striking at the
moment is that the cost of their weekly
shop has gone up by more than their
salary and we don't want to be here in a
year's time having the same discussion
so it is challenging for everyone as we
see when interest rates go up but it's
the right thing to do because if we
bring down inflation we can restore the
value of people's pay packets and stop
people having to worry about prices
going up